c'était il ya soixante ans jour pour
jour le 17 octobre 1961 de nombreux
manifestants algériens sont tués par la
police parisienne leur crime avoir
protesté contre le couvre-feu qui est
imposé par la préfecture de police de
paris aux jeux sites français musulmans
d'algérie
dans le but de mettre un terme sans
délai aux agissements criminels des
terroristes
il est conseillé de la façon la plus
pressante aux travailleurs algériens de
s'abstenir de circuler la nuit dans les
rues de paris et de la banlieue
parisienne et plus particulièrement
entre 20h30 et 5h30 du matin face à ce
couvre-feu qualifiés de racistes par de
nombreux algériens le mouvement
indépendantiste front de libération
nationale appellent à une manifestation
pacifique ils sont ce jour là des
dizaines de milliers arpenté les rues
parisiennes
dix mille d'entre eux venus de la
banlieue ouest de la capitale s'engage
sur le pont de neuilly devant lequel
nous nous trouvons actuellement les
policiers procèdent à des
interpellations ils sont sur le qui vive
à cause de rumeurs sur d'éventuels
manifestants armés ou des morts que l'on
compterait dans les rangs de la police
présents dans d'autres cortèges face à
la pression il frappe des manifestants à
coups de matraque et les premiers coups
de feu sont tirés avant 19 heures des
violences éclatent entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre ailleurs dans d'autres
cortèges encerclé tabassé par des
policiers certains manifestants tombent
dans la seine ce massacre du 17 octobre
1961 et la répression d'état la plus
violente qui ait jamais provoqué une
manifestation en europe occidentale dans
l'histoire contemporaine le lendemain la
préfecture de police de paris fait état
de deux morts parmi les manifestants et
évoque des rassemblements violents et
des attaques de commandos contre la
police - partisans les historiens quant
à eux évaluent le bilan humain du
massacre à un nombre de morts compris
entre 150 et 200 une soixantaine
d'instruction judiciaire sont menées
auprès de policiers qui ont participé à
ces violences mais tout à boutih sade et
non lieu alors que quelques 12000
français musulmans d'algérie sont raflés
des dizaines d'entre eux sont passés à
tabac à coups de crosse et de gourdins
certains sont mêmes tués par balle avant
d'être jeté dans la seine l'état
français va s'employer à dissimuler ce
massacre il faudra attendre plus de
vingt ans pour que des historiens et des
militants ne révèle son ampleur le
mensonge d'état a commencé dès le 18
octobre par la dénégation des victimes
de la répression policière et
l'imputation de la violence aux
manifestants algériens côté responsables
politiques personne n'ait inquiété donc
ni maurice papon préfet de police de
paris ni roger frey ministre de
l'intérieur ni michel debré premier
ministre et encore moins charles de
gaulle président de la république et
version officielle tout s'est passé dans
les règles et aucun débordement n'a
entaché la répression de cette
manifestation au sommet de l'état tout
le monde sait que le bilan officiel est
mensonger la priorité du général de
gaulle et que l'algérie devienne
indépendante et il sait que cela ne se
fera pas sans soubresaut ni violence
prise en tenaille entre une armée et une
police tenté par l'insubordination et un
fln qui n'est pas un interlocuteur
facile il ne s'occupe pas de
l'intendance il faudra attendre
plusieurs décennies jusqu'à la fin des
années 80 pour que la parole se libère
celle notamment d'enfants de
manifestants les manifestants ont mis du
temps avant de raconter en détail ce qui
est arrivé ce jour là il ne voulait pas
qu'on puisse nourrir un sentiment de
haine ou de vengeance envers la
république française dans laquelle nous
étions nés au sommet de l'état il aura
fallu un demi siècle pour qu'un
président français en l'occurrence
françois hollande rente hommage à ces
victimes en reconnaissant officiellement
une répression sanglante des algériens
qui manifestaient pour le droit à
l'indépendance ont été tués lors d'une
sanglante répression
la république reconnaît avec lucidité
c'est fait cinquante et un ans après
cette tragédie
je rends hommage à la mémoire des
victimes six ans plus tard emmanuel
macron lui emboîte le pas et admet je
cite une répression violente
mais l'un comme l'autre n'ont pas été
plus loin que les mots les actes se font
toujours à temps brun